cambodian prime minister hunsen takes a
few uncertain steps as he starts an
official two-day visit to myanmar he's
the first head of state to visit myanmar
since the coup last february and while
the military has rolled out the red
carpet few others welcome the trip
social media inside myanmar has been
full of images like this people showing
their anger at honsen those opposed to
the coup and myanmar's military rulers
fear the visit gives legitimacy to the
regime the people of myanmar are clearly
sending a very strong message
that
hunsan is not welcome in myanmar
they are very upset that the kunsan is
actually providing legitimacy to the
murderous hunter and and which is
actually terrorizing the whole country
there's also concern that hunsen could
open the door that allows myanmar back
into asean the association of southeast
asian nations
south east asian leaders have already
taken an unprecedented stand in
excluding myanmar until certain
conditions are met such as the release
of political prisoners and the end of
violence against protesters
it's unclear how much backing hunsen has
from other regional leaders but his
arrival in myanmar could divide asean
further
it's also very unlikely hunsen will meet
any of the jailed democratic leaders
deposed in the coup but he may be
looking for some time in the global
spotlight himself
hun sen realizes that he is going to
play the center role on the stage he
relishes that
i think it also
is something that makes countries that
have criticized him like the united
states and the european union need him
that they need his cooperation
protesters inside myanmar have
consistently called for the
international community to pay more
attention to their cause but a visit
from one of the longest serving
authoritarian leaders in the world is
unlikely to bring them the attention
they want
tony chang al jazeera